a very warm welcome to all our viewers
i'm anjali from simply learn and today
i'll be taking you through one of the
most basic topics in python variables so
we'll have a look at what is a variable
and then the various data types of
variables we'll also see the rules for
naming these variables after this we'll
check out some of the arithmetic
operations we can perform on the integer
and floated above and the operations on
the string type variables and after this
we'll have a small exercise with strings
also stick on to the end for a short and
fun quiz so let's begin guys so here's a
very simple statement X equal 200 a
variables definition is basically an
entity of a program that holds a value
so in this case X would be our variable
and hundred would be the value it holds
to better visualize this statement let's
consider a box now if this box will the
value say hundred then the name we give
to this box which in our case is X would
be the variable name 100 that is a
content within the box or within the
variable would be the value of the
variable now this is the basics of what
a variable is as we'll go through the
various topics today you'll have a
better understanding of why we use
variables and how to use them so let's
move on to the next topic which is the
various data types of variables before
we move on to this let me explain to you
what data types are if you have dealt
with other programming languages before
you probably already know what data type
is but just in case you haven't data
type is basically the type of value that
you assign to the variable so in a
previous example where we set X equal
200 in layman terms 100 is a number so
the data type would be number but when
we come to programming languages there
are two types of numbers there are
integers and there are floats in
teachers are basically numbers without
decimal point floats are numbers with
decimal point other than this a very
common data type that we have in Python
and other languages is string so string
is any word in technical terms we call
them a collection of characters Python
also has a
few of its own data types as we will see
so let's move on so I'll move on to my
jupiter notebook
so the first data type that we will be
looking at is integer as you saw in our
previous example X equal 200 is an apt
example for this let me run the
statement as you can see there's no
error that means this assignment is
proper now we'll check the type of this
variable so type and within bracket you
enter X run this and as you can see the
type is int so int is a short for
integer any number without a decimal
point comes to int in fights in now this
is not the only way you can assign
values to variables you can also assign
values to variables while simultaneously
performing arithmetic operations on them
so 654 into 6 7 3 4 enter now let's
check out the type of this variable
which would be int again now if you
print the value of this variable you'll
see that the value X tose is the product
of these two numbers so now let's move
on to the next data type which is float
X equal to 3 point 1 4 as you can see
this is a number with a decimal point if
you run this there won't be any error so
this is a proper assignment statement
you print X
and the value is printed now you print
the type of X
Jean and it's float we'll move on to our
next data type which is strings so
string is any word it's a collection of
characters so X equal to and within
quotes
so I'll dive simply learn and run so no
error print X and the value of X is
printed which is simply learn so guys
whenever you're assigning strings to a
variable it's important that you do them
within quotes now you can do them within
single or double quotes I'll show you
how it's done within single quotes
[Music]
and the exact same output so it does not
matter whether you single or double
quotes now let's check out the type of
this variable type X
and STR which is a short form for string
so now that we had a look at integers
floats and strings let's move on to some
of the datatype specific to Python the
first one we look at is lists so a list
is basically a collection of values so
far we assigned a single value to a
variable with lists we can assign
multiple values and this is how it's
done
so give the variable name equal to open
square brackets and within this you type
your values so 1467 nine run this no
error now let's print X and see what
this results in as you see when you
print X all the values you stored within
it is visible now let's check out the
type of X
and the type is list now with list since
there are multiple values stored within
a variable you might be wondering how
you can extract a single value so this
is simple each value in a list has an
index so you always start with 0 this is
the 0th position first position second
position so if you want to extract 14
then you type print x 0 and that will
display 14 if you want to print the last
value print X 2 because we start from 0
so this is 1 and this is 2 so that
should print 9 great now we'll change
the values which are stored within the
list so if I say X 2 which right now is
9 but I want to change this to 67 so
that is a simple statement how you can
do so and run now let's see what X holds
so when you just type X you're printing
every value within X and when you give a
particular number within the square
brackets with X you're printing the
value at that particular location so
print of X run and as you can see here
guys previously X held 1467 9 now it
holds 14 67 and 67 again because we
changed X of 2 to 67 so now that we are
done with list we'll move on to another
data type in Python this is called
tupple so with tupple 2 it's about the
same thing you can store multiple values
in a single variable
the syntax for doing so though is
slightly different with tuples so
instead of square brackets you now have
round rackets and within that you type
in your values so I just put 4 8 6
[Music]
and let's print X
so all the values within X is printed
now let's check the type of X
and the type gives double so you might
be wondering what is the difference
between list and double now the core
difference between list and double is
that tuples are immutable so what I mean
here is that in case of tuples 2 you
access each value within it in the same
way you do with lists so if I want to
access the value 8 in X right now I'll
just give X within square brackets 1 in
this
and it outputs it but now if I want to
change this value so the way of doing
that as we saw with lists is X of 1 and
the value I want to change it to so
let's say 5 and I run this we get an
error so you cannot change the values in
case of tuples
once you have stored the value within
the variable for a couple it remains
that way right till the end and in
technical terms this means that tuples
are immutable
while is for which you can change the
values they are mutable so now we have
something slightly different when we
deal with files we need a variable which
points to a particular file so in
general these are called file pointers
the advantage of having file pointers is
that when you need to perform various
operations on a file instead of
providing the files entire path name or
the files name every time we can just
assign it to a particular variable and
use a variable instead so this is
exactly the advantage variables have
with all other values too but the syntax
for doing through with files is slightly
different so I give X equal to open and
within brackets open quotes enter your
file name so I want to open say a file
called variable underscore comp and this
is IP ynb so it's my Python notebook and
the mode I'd like to open it in so R let
me run this no error so it's fine this
kind of an assignment is completely
legit now we check the type of X
so as you see here the type for X is
underscore IO dot txt IO trapper so in
Python this is the particular type
assigned to this variable but in general
terms you can refer to them as file
pointers now suppose you want to assign
values to multiple variables what you
can do here is instead of having
statements like X equal to 5
enter Y equal to 10 enter Z equal to 7
instead of having 3 such statements
delete Open bracket X Y Z within bracket
equal to
five ten seven and this works exactly
the same so now if you print X
[Music]
why and see
[Music]
you'll see that they have been assigned
the respective values of course a number
of variables and the number of values on
either side should match so if you put X
equal to Y so if you give X comma y
equal to five ten seven this would
result in an error because you have only
two variables on your left-hand side
while you have three values on your
right-hand side now suppose you want to
assign the same value to multiple
variables in that case you can do now
suppose you want to assign a value to
multiple variables say X equal to 1 y
equal to 1 Z equal to 1 a short-form to
this as you saw previously would be X
comma Y comma Z equal to 1 comma 1 comma
1 but then again you have to type the
same value 3 times instead what we can
do is X equal to y equal to Z equal to 1
and this would work perfectly fine so if
I print the value of x y&z now
they all have the value once stored
within them so we have covered the
various data types in Python and how you
can assign values to a variable in
multiple ways we'll next move on to the
various rules for naming the variables
now there are certain rules that you
must follow while naming the variables
we will go through each of these rules
and simultaneously I will also
demonstrate to you in our notebook the
validity of each variable so our first
rule is variable name must begin with an
alphabet or an underscore so let's move
on to a notebook so ABC equal 200 this
should be valid because it starts with
an alphabet at the same time underscore
ABC would also be valid
so if the variable starts with an
alphabet or an underscore it's a valid
name for the variable but if we say 3a
equal to 10 this would result in an
error of course because the variable
name starts with the number and this is
invalid same way we cannot start the
variable name with the special character
other than underscore so if I say at the
rate ABC this would also result in an
error as you see the errors invalid
syntax because that is the invalid
syntax for a variable name let's now
look at the second rule for naming
variables the first character can be
followed by alphabets numbers or
underscore so our first character must
be an alphabet or an underscore and
after this first character we can have
alphabets we can have numbers or we can
have underscore so back to our notebook
by the second rule a hundred should be
valid as it is and if we put underscore
which is a valid starting character a
nine eight four so our first characters
followed by a letter three digits and
then another underscore
this should also be valid because at the
end of the day it only consists of
numbers letters and an underscore
however if our variable name is a 9 9 6
7 few digits and then a dollar sign with
this work well note this would result in
an error invalid syntax because as
already mentioned for variable names the
only special character you can use is
underscore what about X Y Z - 2 again
this would be invalid because it
includes a special character that is not
underscore can't assign to operator
let's have a look at a third rule
variable names are case sensitive so
what kiss sensitive means is that small
littles and capital letters are treated
differently so let's move back to a
notebook and see I assign a value
hundred to a variable a hundred small E
and I assign another value 200 to a
different variable capital 800 so as you
see here guys between these two
variables
the only difference is that the first
variable has a small E and the second
variable has a capital M let me just
execute this if I print the value of a
hundred
and capital 800 you'll see that both
these variables are recognized as
completely different variables they have
they individual values so now that we
establish that variables are case
sensitive we can also say that python
itself is a case sensitive language now
a final rule is that reserved words
cannot be used as variable names now if
you have gone through any other
languages like C C++ Java you know this
is a common rule among all of them you
cannot use words which have special
meaning to the language as variable
names so some of these words are break
class try you have other words such as
continue while which is a loop or if
which is a statement a conditional
statement so let's go back to our
notebook and see how assigning values to
these reserved words can result in
errors so if I give break equal to 10
that would be an error
similarly loss equal to 5 would result
in an error try equal 200 would also
result in an error because these words
break last try has special meaning to
Python and with that we cover the
various rules for naming variables the
next thing we will check out is the
arithmetic operations that you can
perform on these variables once you have
stored integer values in them also
perform various arithmetic operations
with variables that store integer or
float values so let's have a look at
some of these operations that we can
perform we will start with initializing
two variables so X equal to 20 and y
equal to 10 and now we will perform our
operations with these two variables so
first let's check out how addition works
result equal to X plus y so result is a
new variable and it should store the
value of x plus y let's print this out
and as you see X plus y equal to 30 so
now results those 30 similarly we can
perform subtraction
we'd print this out too
so 20 minus 10 is 10 we can also perform
multiplication
we use Astrix for the multiplication
sign
so 22 10 that's 200 next we'll check out
division
so as you can see here in case of
division the result is not an integer
but rather a float if you want your
result in integer what you can do is
instead of putting just one slash you
can apply two slashes so X slash slash Y
and print the result and there you go
now you have the result in integer so in
this particular case since then
completely divides 20 the requirement of
the double slash is not very visible but
if we do division for numbers that are
not divided each other completely for
example if we have result equal to 2 by
3 we print the result we get zero point
six six and so on but if we give double
slash here
and run this we get the result as zero
so in a lot of cases the result from
double slash makes way more sense then
from single slash so this is an extra
benefit you have with Python which is
not present in many other languages we
also have the modulus operator here
which gives the remainder rather than
the quotient so if I see X mod Y will
give me the remainder of the divisions
from X by Y and the remainder 0 because
10 completely divides 20 on the other
hand if you do want to see the remainder
you can give numbers such as 3 by 3 more
2 and then fill in the result and as you
see the remainder of this operation
would be 1 now so far we saw arithmetic
operations with integers all these
operations can also be performed with
floating-point numbers so if your x
value is 3.14 and your Y value is 5.7
let's just perform one operation using
the new values of x and y to see what it
looks like
select a result equal to X by Y
print result and there's your quotient
so arithmetic operations work both with
integers and floating point numbers next
let's check out some of the operations
you can perform on string variables as I
mentioned earlier strings are basically
a collection of characters so let's look
at a few string operations first we'll
initialize a string variable so we're
going to simply learn and we'll perform
all our operations on this vat variable
now the first thing we will do with this
string variable is we will see how we
can extract each character string so
just like in case of lists and tuples
every character in your string has an
index and it always starts with 0 so the
first character is at location 0 second
at one third at two and so on so if you
want to extract the first character of
your string which is s in our case we
just do bad of 0 and as you see s is
printed similarly if you want to extract
the 5th character of a string we'll put
bad of foo so if you want to extract end
character your index for it would be n
minus 1 because we start our index from
0 and that prints L so as you can see
here s is 0 and then we have 1 2 3 4 and
that is L so now that we learn how to
extract a single character let's see how
we can extract multiple characters from
the string suppose I want to extract the
first three characters in that case I
would say pad of the first three so my
starting character would be at 0 so if I
want to extract the first three
characters of my string what I'm
basically saying is that I want to
extract the character at the zero at
first and second position then I'd say
print off bad off starting from the
zeroth location up to the third location
we say 3 and not 2 because the last
index is always excluded so if I put two
here instead of three then only the 0 it
and the first character
would be printed so I want my first
three characters reprinted so far of
zero to three and I'll run this and as
you see the first three characters have
been printed capital S followed by I M
now if you want to start from your first
character you can also just ignore the
zero so you can see bad off :
three that is we are not typing the zero
in this case it's automatically
understood that you start extracting
from the first character when you miss
out the zero so you run this and as you
see it's the same result now if you want
to print the character starting from the
fifth location until the end of the
string you can go with print off bad of
5th character so 5 and up to the end in
this case you do not need to mention the
last index you can just leave it blank
and it's automatically understood that
you're printing till the very last
character of your string and as you see
from your 5th index to the very last
character has been printed now suppose
you give ware of 0 to 20 and it's pretty
obvious that you do not have 20
characters in this particular string so
you do not have 20 indexes so what do
you think would happen if I do 0 to 20
well the entire string is printed so
although we have only 11 characters in
our string and we have given the ending
index as 20 this does not result in an
error just our entire string gets
printed now if you want to find out the
length of your string without actually
having to count it manually you can use
the function Len of bad Len is an infill
function in Python now run the command
and as you can see we have 11 characters
in our string so those are the basic
operations you can do with a string
variable I hope this is very clear to
you as in the end we have a small quiz
which uses some of these concepts so now
that we have gone through the base
concepts of variables let's have a small
exercise where we'll be using string
variables so we'll have two strings one
string says it's Sunday and the other
stores have a great day using only these
two strings we need to build a third
string with
it's a great Sunday so let's have a look
at how to do this we move back to our
notebook the first thing to do is we
store our two so strings in separate
variables so let's have variable bad one
which stores our first string it's
Sunday and we have the next variable bad
two which stores our second string have
a great day
now using these two strings we create
our third string which is bad three
so first let's run these two statements
so now bad three needs to store it's a
great Sunday the word it's comes from
bad one so bad one and it starts at the
first location so zero which we can
ignore because it's automatically
assumed to be zero and we require all
the characters in bad one from the zero
with position until the position just
before our capital s of Sunday so that
would be zero one two three four
so our fourth position is the blank
space since we want to include the blank
space too we give our ending index as
five
now the next part of a string it's a
great Sunday needs to include a great
from bad to so bad too
so the next part of a string is a great
and ugly it comes from bad too now this
subscript starts from the fifth position
in bar 2 so a starting position would be
5 and either 12 position in bar - we
have the space that comes up - great
now we need to include the space - so
we'll go with our ending index as 13 and
finally our last word of its a great
Sunday which is Sunday will come from
bad one so we're one and the word Sunday
starts from the fifth location in bar 1
so our starting index here would be 5
and we'll take the entire string from
the 5th location so we leave the ending
index empty and that's it so let's run
this now let's just check if what we did
so far is correct so we'll print we're
three and yeah that's perfect as you can
see we have it's a great Sunday in bad 3
which is exactly what we wanted so now a
short quiz for you
so if you're familiar with other
programming languages but for those who
are completely new to programming
languages definitely try this out so we
have a variable a which holds a value
hundred and we'll have another variable
B which holds a value 200 now the task
is we won't be to hold the value hundred
and eight to hold the value 200 so
basically you're swapping the values
between these two variables
so give this a thought and post your
answers in the comment section below
we'll give out the answers soon enough
and with that we come to an end of
Python variables I hope you like this
video if so please hit the like button
also subscribe to our channel if you
haven't yet
this is Angela signing off have a great
day
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simple learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here